we're going through some tough economic
times right now but this holiday season
take a moment to appreciate how good
things really are remember Christmas in
the 70s sure we were excited to open
presents back then but that's only
because we didn't know how much those
presents sucks compared to the presents
we buy our kids today now we can play at
the same time I'm office I'm deep in the
70s we play koliko head-to-head football
this is real competition today kids get
to play mat in the 70s we got excited
about pong today kids get excited about
the amazing online game World of
Warcraft in the 70s there were only
three broadcast networks it's a good
time today we enjoy hundreds of cable
channels more than a hundred thousand
movie choices have netflix and millions
of videos at youtube back then you could
buy a computer that didn't do very much
for twenty thousand dollars you're
looking at a small portable computer
called the IBM 5100 today for a few
hundred bucks you can use this little
contraption to download and watch a 70s
commercial for an IBM 5100 it's bringing
the advantages of the computer to more
and more people thanks to our
market-based system we have better stuff
and lower prices than ever before but
that's not the best part today people
live longer start working later in life
and retire earlier and work fewer hours
a week than ever before and that means
we'll all have more leisure time to
spend with our loved ones this holiday
season from all of us at reason TV happy
holidays
you